So average precision is computed
for just one query.
But we generally experiment
with many different queries and
this is to avoid the variance across
queries.
Depending on the queries you use, you
might make different conclusions, so
it's better to use more queries.
If you use more queries then you would
also have to take average of the
average precision over all these
queries.
So how can we do that?
You can naturally think of just doing
arithmetic mean as we know.
Always tend to think in this way. So this would give us what is called Mean Average Precision or MAP. In this case we take arithmetic mean of all the average precisions over set of queries or topics.
But as I just mentioned in another
lecture, is this good?
Recall that we talked about the
different ways of combining precision
and recall. And
we conclude that the arithmetic mean is
not as good as the F measure.
But here it's the same.
We can also think about the alternative
ways of aggregating the numbers.
Don't just automatically assume that.
Let's just take the arithmetic mean of
the average precision over these
queries.
Let's think about what's the best way
of aggregating.
If you think about different ways,
naturally you would probably be able
to think about another way, which is
geometric mean.
And we called this kind of average gMAP
map.
This is another way.
So now, once you think about the two
different ways of doing the same thing,
the natural question to ask is which
one is better so.
So do you use MAP or gMAP?
Again, that's important question.
Imagine you are again testing a new
algorithms by comparing it with your
old algorithm in the search engine.
Now you test it on multiple topics.
Now you've got the average precisions
for all these topics.
Now you are thinking of looking at the
overall performance you have to take
average.
But which which strategy would you use?
Now first
you should also think about the
question, would it make a difference?
Can you think of scenarios where using
one of them would make a difference?
That is, they would give different the
rankings of those methods.
And that also means depending on the
way you average, or you take the
average of these average precisions,
you will get different conclusions.
This makes the question become even
more important.
So which one would you use?
Again, if you look at the difference
between these different ways of
aggregating the average position, you
will realize in arithmetic mean the sum
is dominant by large values.
So what does a large menu value here
mean?
It means the query is relatively easy.
You can have a high average precision,
where as gMAP tends to be
affected more by lower values and those
are the queries that don't have good
performance.
The average precision is low.
So if you think about improving the
search engine for those difficult
queries than gMAP would be preferred.
On the other hand, that if you just
want to have improvement over all the
kinds of queries or particular popular
queries, that might be easy and you
want to make the perfect and maybe MAP
would be them preferred.
So again, the answer depends on your
users, your user's tasks, and their
preferences.
So the point that here is.
To think about the multiple ways to
solve the same problem and then compare
them and think carefully about
differences and which one makes more
sense.
Often in one of them might make sense
in one situation and another might make
more sense in a different situation, so
it's important to figure out under what
situations one is preferred.
As a special case of the mean average
precision, we can also think about the
case where there is precisely one
relevant document.
And this happens often.
For example, in what's called a known item
search, where you know a target page.
Let's say you want to find the Amazon
home page, you have one relevant
document there, and you hope to find
it.
And that's called the known item
search.
In that case, there is precisely one
relevant document, or in another
application like a question answering.
Maybe there's only one answer there, so
if you rank the answers, then your goal
is ranked at one particular answer on
top right?
So in this case, you can easily verify,
the average precision will basically
boil down
two reciprocal rank, that is one
over R, where R is the rank position
of that single relevant document.
So if that document is ranked on the
very top, R is 1 and then it's one for
reciprocal rank.
If it's ranked at the second, then it's
1 / 2 etc.
And then we can also take a average of
all these average position or
reciprocal rank over a set of topics
and that would give us something called
Mean Reciprocal Rank. It is a very popular
value for known item search or any
ranking problem where you have just one
relevant item.
Now again, here you can see this R
actually is meaningful here, and this
R is basically indicating how much
effort an user would have to make in
order to find that relevant document.
If it's ranked on the top is no effort
that you have to make or little effort,
but if it's ranked at 100 then you
actually have to read presumably 100
documents in order to find it.
So in this sense,
R is also meaningful measure and the
reciprocal rank will take the
reciprocal of R instead of using R
directly.
So one natural question here is, why
not simply using R?
Now imagine if you are to design a
measure to measure performance of the
ranking system when there is only one
relevant item.
You might have thought about using r
directly as the measure.
After all that measures the users
effort, right?
But think about, if you take the
average of this over a large number of
topics,
again, it would make a difference right,
for one single topic using R or using
one overall wouldn't make any
difference.
It's the same
larger R with correspond to a small
one overall, but the difference would
only show when show up when you have
many topics.
So again think about average of mean
reciprocal rank versus average of just
R.
What's the difference?
Do you see any difference?
And would this difference change the
order of systems
in our conclusion?
And it turns out that there is actually
a big difference, and if you think
about it, if you want to think about it
and then yourself, then pause the video.
Basically the difference is if you take
some of R directly, then again will
be dominated by large values of R.
So what are those values?
Those are basically large values that
indicate the lowly ranked results.
That means the relevant item is ranked
very low
down on the list and the sum, the
audacity.
Also the average would be then
dominated by where those relevant
documents are ranked in the lower
portion of the ranked list, but from a
user's perspective we care more about
the highly ranked documents.
So by taking this transformation by
using reciprocal rank,
here we emphasize more on the
difference on the top and think about
the difference between one and two.
It will make a big difference.
In one over R, but think about 100 and
101 and one it won't make much
difference if you use this.
But if you use this, there will be a
big difference.
Being 100 and let's say 1000.
Right, so this is not the desirable.
On the other hand, one and two won't make
much difference, so this is yet another
case where there may be multiple
choices of doing the same thing, and
then you need to figure out which one
makes more sense.
So to summarize, we
show the Precision recall curve,
can characterize the overall accuracy
of a ranked list.
And we
emphasized that the actual utility over
ranking list that depends on how many
top rankings results are user would
actually examine.
Some users will examine more than
others and average precision is the
standard measure for comparing two
ranking methods.
It combines precision and recall and
it's sensitive to the rank of every
relevant the document.